tyler malley is on the mound for
cincinnati's coming off a brilliant
outing a season high seven innings two
runs seven hits in denver and this is a
guy who has an era south of three on the
year he keeps getting better the past
few seasons popped up it's for winker to
make the catch one down now at one point
darren ruff was a platoon player for san
francisco linked up with the team last
year mostly playing against left-handed
pitching but gabe kepler said even
though he's better against southpaws he
works a great at bat against everyone
great battle here he's giving his
teammates a lot of looks he's just
trying to run the pitch count up eighth
pitch of the at-bat finds some open
space and darren ruff is in business
heading for two and he is in there with
a one out double honestly that was as
big of a big as bad as you can have in a
baseball game great job setting the
table for brandon crawford underwater
swing crawford down on strikes mally
pulls him there for out number two evan
longoria who's one for eight in this
series with four strikeouts hitting the
ball as hard as he ever has in his
career payoff pitch is past mali and
past the infield it's a base hit ruff
being waved around he's going to come in
and score easily it's an rbi knock for
evan longoria to break the ice for san
francisco it's one nothing even if they
just come away with run run here a
highly successful very giants giants-ish
first inning one-two got him malley
picks up two strikeouts reds give up a
run in the first johnny cueto on the
mound today for the giants is actually
the third day in a row with a former red
starting for san francisco jesse winker
leads off and he's going to get a free
pass to start the day troublesome start
for him first two of the game for
cincinnati reach
winker walks castiano singles and that
brings us to tyler stevenson who's been
electric at home this year just what he
needs the giants turn two
and tyler stevenson is doubled up as
winker moves to third big ground ball
out 94. he don't seem that i think his
lat's doing okay
there's the stuff it's there for quito
just had to get settled in to reach no
problem two on to start this third
inning for san francisco gosh dang it
brandon crawford drops one into right
and yostremski's being waved around and
he will come in to make it two-nothing
san francisco it's an rbi knock for
brandon crawford to drive in the second
run of the day as here's
alex dickerson here he lines this one to
right it's going to be a base hit one
run scores they stay loaded it's three
nothing no outs mauricio dubon up next
dubon to the right side with open space
and that'll score another one for the
giants they move station to station and
make it four-nothing and they're all
over tyler malley so it's an unfortunate
outing for him david bell takes the
baseball michael feliz is summoned from
the bullpen in a four-nothing game and a
ton of trouble brewing here stephen
dugger's the batter with the bases
loaded in the zone 95 down it's socked
by duggar as naquin gives it a look and
it's gone
steven duggar loads up and it's a grand
slam for the giants to make it eight
nothing san francisco what a blast off
the bat of duggar his second of the
season and he was all over that fastball
they score seven in this third inning
and we continue with darren ruff his
second trip to the plate in this frame
darren rough
yeah it's going into the seats about the
third row
second home run of the inning for the
giants as they power up darren ruff with
a two-run shot to make it 10-0 stand up
double to lead off the bottom of the
third for the reds
castillanos up the middle and the reds
break the ice their first run comes in
it's blandino scoring on the rbi single
from nick 10-1 this is a situation for
johnny where i've gotta if i'm him it's
like i have to bear down right here
because i've got two outs i've let a run
cross already ten to one no big deal
this is a big at-bat for him right now
tyler naked got him great pitch
big time change up from johnny cueto
that is his best pitch and he uses it to
escape gives up one run to the reds
they're up big the giants 10-1 that ball
skips away there's a run for san
francisco
just for a moment there duggar comes in
it's 11-1
giants here in the fifth crawford
sends one deep right field
forget about it
brandon crawford muscles up for a
three-run shot ambush right there and
it's the second one off of embry in this
series casalli is hit by a pitch for the
second time today wait hold on the race
is on for darren ruff
he is going to hold up at sackey a
triple shot
tried it two out double for darren ruff
have a day hey that's gonna score one
and here comes another brandon crawford
brings in two more for san francisco to
make it 16-1 casalli and ruff come on
down and the giants are one away from
matching the most runs we've seen in a
baseball game from one team this season
evan longoria has left the yard it's a
two run homer and the giants have scored
more runs in a game than any team this
season an 18 spot well now the reds have
the bases loaded max schrock just called
up today that one gets away
and
in comes a run for cincinnati it's 18-2
that's suarez scoring
one for nine the reds with runners in
scoring position payoff to schrock
got him right-handed hitting a eugenio
suarez who's over two with a walk that
is ship to left off the bat of suarez it
is gone 0-2 pitch gino suarez likes it
and he muscles up for his
season he just went with the pitch and
put a good swing on it and it was a
homer max schrock in the game now here
it is and longoria swings and lifts a
fly ball along the right field line
moving quickly toward the foul line now
racing over and missing the ball is the
right fielder peyton but i think it was
a foul ball no it was a fair ball and it
bounced up into the stands
it's going to be an automatic double so
alvarez is in the score matt whistler is
the new pitcher for san francisco
slider guy a little too much over the
plate so far this year when you have
three world series rings and i have none
there's things i have to talk yeah
homers it's awesome game
over that's it no more bragging about
your career
[Music]
matt whistler said i've had enough
giants win they sweep the reds in a
four-game set